regardez-vous dans la glace
tomber amoureux de vous et ensuite les
autres
[Musique]
salut je m'appelle Bilal Hassani et je
suis actuellement au Festival de Cannes
pour une incroyable montée des marches
celle du Diana John
c'est une chanson qui évoque un petit
peu
ce travail que je fais avec moi-même en
fait si c'est de m'imaginer de me mettre
dans la position de du Nikon tout le
temps je pense que c'est très important
d'avoir confiance en soi pour se faire
une place dans ce monde et pour et pour
se sauver parfois des situations qui
peuvent être un petit peu embarrassantes
ou potentiellement va vous dire que vous
êtes moins que et ben si vous faites pas
confiance à vous même la personne qui le
fera pour vous donc c'est un petit peu
cette certaine power rang que je cherche
à prouver à montrer dans la chaussure
ce lieu aussi le Palais des Festivals et
ses marches elles sont tellement
iconiques bien sûr quelque chose de
mystique un petit peu qui se passe
là-bas qu'on peut même pas expliquer je
crois
je pense que que l'art en général la
plupart de changer les choses et au bout
de changer le monde je pense que
l'art en fait rentre dans le consuel
inconscient des humains tout le temps en
constante et que parfois des films oui
on fait avancer des choses j'ai déjà vu
des films en tout cas aider à faire
bouger les lignes de des mentalités je
sais que les larmes en général sert
beaucoup et souvent à ça
qui est important toujours et et c'est
la représentation je pense qu'il est
important de caster des personnes courir
et de et de raconter des histoires cuir
et on en a besoin de plus en plus parce
qu'il en a des très belles qui sont
racontées depuis quelques années
mais il en faut encore
[Musique]
comme être iconique sur le tapis rouge
je pense que à partir du moment où on
sait qui on est et ben on le projette
correctement pour les autres donc
regardez-vous dans la glace
tomber amoureux de vous et ensuite les
autres amoureux